what's the difference between goals and
vision so I got a great question for my
newsletter viewers readers love you guys
nitesh who wrote in to say dear Evan
thinking once again for sharing your
thoughts and examples I'm happy to learn
it I have a question for you I'd like to
know your views on it because in this
topic I find my mind wandering but
lately I'm trying my best to get focused
what is goals and vision what does it
mean to you what are the differences
between them why is it so important to
write down your goals I'm looking
forward to your views on it
I really want to learn on this topic I
want to have a vision and set goals
thank you nitesh so it's important as an
entrepreneur to have both vision and
goals and here's what the difference is
your vision is the better world that you
see the world that you want to help
create so for me I might say I envision
a world where people learn to follow
their passion we're growing up in school
when your parents and your community you
learn that following your passion is
important where do we learn that we
don't learn that anywhere you don't
learn that in school we learn about you
know math and history and all that is
important and give us the tools to
succeed in a job
but where do you ever learn that hey
following your passion is important I
envision a world and I'm trying to help
create that world where that is a
reality I envision a world where people
believe in themselves where they have
the self-confidence to launch their own
things to know that it's going to work
to not listen to the little man in their
lives who tell them that it's not going
to happen I envision where where there's
no little man right where this is this
is something that people strive to do
that it's just natural and normal and
commonplace that you believe in yourself
and you are following your passion ah
this is this is ingrained into me now
and I try to help other people see that
and envision a world where everybody is
on the same page that's a vision right
what better world do you want to create
okay it's a big picture thing your goals
are more tangible they're quantifiable
they're measurable they're steps to help
you accomplish your vision that
dreamy world that I just talked about
how do I make that happen what are some
measurable goals that I can go towards
so for example if my vision was I want
everybody in North America to grow up
learning how to believe in themselves
and to follow their passion okay I think
that math and history are important
subjects and following your passion is
just as important and giving people the
skills and tool sets to do it so that's
the vision I'm creating a goal might be
that every high school in North America
has a class dedicated to teaching people
the importance of how to find your
passion and the steps on how to do it
right so that's a goal it's quantifiable
it's measurable and if I achieve that
then you can go to a bigger goal and a
bigger goal and a bigger goal and all
these goals that you track and measure
build up to help you create your bigger
vision this huge vision of the world
that you want to change okay so that's
the difference again vision big picture
almost intangible it's something that
makes you feel something right it's a
it's a better place for the world that
you may never even accomplish in your
lifetime goals quantifiable smaller
measurable and stepping stones to get to
your vision you start up with a smaller
goal and build up until you get to your
bigger goal bigger goal big Google as
you build towards a better world and
creating your vision making it reality
thanks for the great question believe
for those who are watching I'd love to
hear what your goals are what your
visions are leave them in the comments
below let me know what you think the
differences are I'd love to hear your
feedback and you have a question for me
you leave it below too and make a video
response you like the video give it a
thumbs up makes trying to do more for
you and click on my face to subscribe to
the channel thank you so much I'll see
you soon
you